foreign
good thing his wife's a doctor
[Applause]
[Music]
yes oh my goodness happy Thursday
everyone it's June 1st and you know what
that means Pat Boone's Birthday
[Applause]
everyone right now do a shot of relief
Factor
but also it's pride month and you will
be happy about it or else just ask
Toronto Blue Jays pitcher Anthony bass I
know who knew Toronto had Sports
this week he posted a pro-christian
video to his Instagram account
supporting boycotts of Target and Bud
Light those are the companies you know
who support men with junk entering
women's locker rooms armed with their
own built-in towel hanger
so after some blowback he he
I didn't mean it that way
it's Louisiana time you did yeah I know
who knew so after some blowback did the
player hold his ground and stick to his
Christian beliefs nope like Joy Behar
sucking down a pruned mojito
he released a hot steaming pile of crap
I recognized yesterday I made a post
that was hurtful to the pride Community
which includes friends of mine and close
family members of mine and I am truly
sorry for that
um I just spoke with my teammates and
shared within my actions yesterday I
apologize with them and as right now I'm
using the Blue Jays resources to better
educate myself to make better decisions
moving forward the ballpark is for
everybody we include all fans at the
Ballpark and we want to welcome
everybody that's all I have to say
thank you
better educate himself well that had all
the sincerity of Hannibal Lecter telling
his date that the ketchup is for a hot
dog
still the player he groveled like Hunter
at a strip club without his ATM card sad
every word of that forced apology Came
From the Bottom of some lawyer's
shriveled Blackhearts
so what did he do that was so hurtful he
shared a video and you don't have to
agree with the video but so what in
today's world if you're a Christian and
don't want trans propaganda dangled in
your face like a weighing popped free
from a women's swimsuit that's too damn
bad
you're supposed to just shut up about it
sure leftists could scare authors
broadcasters and even bakeries with mob
persecution but pipe down you Christians
because trans are a marginalized
Community although does it really seem
like they're in the margins anymore they
have more visible Flags than the UN gift
shop I haven't seen this many rainbows
since I crashed that leprechaun
convention
yeah and whatever the event you better
applaud with tears in your eyes or else
you're a transphobe refusing to do what
you're told is bigotry again Anthony
bass didn't say any of that bible stuff
himself but he agreed with it which is
gross because yuck it's Christianity and
according to Major League Baseball
Christians are open for mockery not
support the LA Dodgers face a backlash
for reinviting the Sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence a group of transvestites
dressed as nuns to present them with a
community hero award or cha
[Laughter]
at the team's Pride night later this
month this is a group known for mocking
Christians of course including actually
holding pole dancing on crosses now what
do a group of transvestite atheists have
to do with baseball anyway you know
other than they both like rubbing pine
tar on their bats
nothing
just like what Dylan Mulvaney had to do
with beer nothing but that's not the
point the point is to rile you up get in
your face so they can then condemn you
for your dismay even more it's a sport
always has been and if you don't play
then you're the problem after rescinding
their initial invite the Dodgers were
cowed into submission by a small group
of activists and now they're alienating
their own fans so what's next I guess
now when they call Ball Four it means
you're getting flashed by two nuns with
beards
it's funny
so what have we learned well for one
corporate executives are and that
condition is contagious
and all protected celebrations of
identity do is so division creating
tripwires and fake sins designed to
scare everyone else into obeyance even
bass is now getting blow back from
Christians see he should have just shut
up but how can you when everyone has to
get involved including PetSmart
yeah even dogs are pro Pride
which makes sense they're on all fours
and always looking for ass
but in my opinion if you want acceptance
why not just be more like us be boring
but it appears if there's one thing
certain members of the trans Lobby won't
tolerate besides high heels under a size
10. it's not being the center of
attention the bullied are now the
bullies not sure this is the
transformation they were looking for
yes welcome tonight's guests
if this McDonald had a farm it would be
for the return on investment host of the
evening edit on Fox Business lives
to be here tonight he got his mom to
cover his paper route most of the guy
Benson show guy Betsy
well she kills people with kindness and
drain cleaner Fox News contributor cat
tip
and his handshakes require a safe word
my massive sidekick in the NWA World
Heavyweight Champion Tyra
guy uh I'm actually Pro pride month just
because it's actually non-serious it
doesn't have a lot of solemn like
vocations and moments it's just people
having fun but after a while I mean a
month is a month that's like a month of
Mother's Days hey I love my mother but
you only get one day
why do gays get 30 and my mom only got
one
should I Blame You guy is it your fault
probably not but go ahead all right it's
your fault guy I mean it does feel a
little bit less fun these days though it
doesn't because of uh some of the
stories that you were just talking about
I was struck watching that groveling
scripted apology from the Blue Jays
pitcher
and
I remember I'm so old that I recall when
we were told by all the journalists that
athletes speaking their political values
and truths actually was one of the
highest values they could espouse it
doesn't matter like the whole shut up
and play thing was wrong and bad even
racist but this guy shared one video and
he's immediately out there talking about
how well actually sorry I didn't mean
that I'm going to educate myself
everyone's welcome at the ballpark but
Major League Baseball actually said if
you're a republican in Georgia you're
not welcome at the All-Star Game in
Georgia like they they have all these
different rules and different standards
one of which with the whole Dodgers
thing watching you explain that
I don't care about this group the
sisters or whatever but their whole
shtick is to intentionally offend to
gratuitously offend and what the Dodgers
are doing here is making clear that
certain people are open to be offended
that way but other people are not right
so for example at Christian night which
they're having at the Ballpark if they
said oh we're going to invite those
Westboro God hates gays freaks I don't
think that that would be acceptable on
Christian night if they were to have at
Pride night these same guys doing a drag
show about Muhammad's wives you know I
don't think that probably happens right
because certain groups you can
gratuitously offend apparently in other
groups you can't and I think we should
on a serious note think about why those
standards exist because it's going to
piss people off and that's why you're
seeing some of the backlash that we're
seeing when I don't think it's necessary
in the first place if we just stuck with
the fun side of Pride exactly you know
uh if they do have a Christian night how
much you want to bet they invite lions
oh
just came up with that just now uh-huh
yeah don't give them ideas
Liz it's like Blue Jays more like BJs am
I right
it doesn't make any sense but I had to
say it to you why did you give that one
to me he gave it to me I would have beat
him right here in front of everybody but
you know what it's like he offended a
religion a religion and I find that
you're very you wrote a book you wrote a
religious book well we don't have to get
into that but yes but yeah we're at a
book skirting heresy yes true story blah
blah you could get it on Amazon but you
know here's the thing you know if you
have to bully to make your point if you
have to throw your toys out of the
playpen to make your point then you're
really not ready to make your point if
you had to force people to think the way
you do then you then you're not ready to
really legitimately stand up as a mature
adult and say Here's my point of view
can you think the way I see my point of
view and by the way I'm not you know I
get it I I hear what guy is saying that
they they I don't know why they had to
wear white face on their you know it has
a nut whatever you know it's just so
much acting out it gets really tedious
and I don't care if they get upset at
what we're saying right now I really
don't care you go to a ballpark looking
like that there are children at the
Ballpark they scare me the way they look
and I don't scare easy I mean they're
just it looks just so stupid and weird
um and the other thing too is I'm always
mindful of what like Liberace and
Rolling Stones the members of The
Rolling Stones said they they until
lately they they never talked politics
yeah Liberace purposely said I'm not
going to talk politics it's not my place
it's and so why baseball is getting into
this it's just it just feels like the
NFL kneeling controversy all over again
and I think baseball should stay away
from it be like I said what it's about
having a good time at the Ballpark
that's it it's all being fueled by this
Dei that's showing up in in corporations
everywhere cat I tried to find a story
that would combine two things you love
which is baseball and trans
laughs
are you ready what do you what do you
feel about this particular story anger
pain I feel nothing
and it's hard it's a hard month for
those of us who feel nothing yeah
yes why don't we talk about that yes I
don't have deeply held beliefs in terms
of religion or in terms of look if you
I'm just one of those people it's like
if you want to be a drag queen that's
cool you're a Christian that's cool but
unfortunately every party's a pitchfork
party nowadays yes and those of us just
want to hang it's like you can't do that
anymore I think I was gonna I was
thinking about taking the entire month
of June off
but then I don't think that was an
option no unless I was pregnant or
having a baby in which case I would have
had to have gotten started earlier
is that how it works uh I Googled it oh
geez yeah so tired so would you have any
big plans for pride month
[Laughter]
I'm gonna breed
just a big old breeder over here
big phobic breeder
big fallopian tube guys I'll work on
that
um
look at this poor face I know that face
the face I make when I'm forced to
apologize at home for saying something
in my own house that I pay the mortgage
in
sorry sir I didn't mean to laugh at your
PR bench press record I would work on it
he's a pitcher he's not a star he
doesn't have you money so when you have
few money you can stand for your
principles
but that wasn't his speech and you want
it was the one guy
who heard it who was above him they
probably told him this is their fastest
way to go to the minor leagues we're not
going to start you tonight because in
his speech he let you know that he's
going to go into the Blue Jays team
apparently they have a team for this to
educate him right which just means they
threaten me with my job and I don't want
to lose my job because I want to I want
to keep pitching so he had to
do what they told them to do and and it
sucks because we should be able to guys
eloquent point we should be able to
celebrate differences and have a
difference of opinion about something
without it being hateful or talking or
trash talking or whatever and then we're
just unfortunately it's not the group
it's not the masses you know it's these
individuals these virtue signalers who
are sitting in these offices that make
these decisions and they are so proud of
themselves because they they kept him in
line because right now being a Christian
and having values is a Bad Thing hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else